hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
january 4th 2021
hey happy new year to
you for you're a jolly good fellow
and you over in the corner
hey it's 2021 everybody we made it
through 2020.
you know doesn't it feel different
doesn't it it feels so much different
i can just feel that this is gonna be a
better year
um all right we shall see a lot of funny
[ __ ] a lot of funny [ __ ] happened this
week
all those [ __ ] idiots out there in
atlanta
[ __ ] going out on new year's eve
going out on new year's eve and all of
these [ __ ] who are yelling at the
government going look what they're doing
to small businesses
where are they when they see these
[ __ ] idiots
walking around not socially distancing
like it's
it's new year's thief i'm an american
what are they gonna take away next
easter
jesus christ this whole [ __ ] pandemic
and and people working together has been
an abject failure
i don't even know how to spell that word
i don't know if i'm saying it right i
just know when something really fails
this is when you use this expression
this is what it's been
the problem has [ __ ] been we are only
as good as the dumbest [ __ ] out
here
that's it all it takes is one dum-dum so
i'm starting a new
[ __ ] a new uh uh whatever
section is that what you call it a new
idea new segment there we go
a new segment i'm calling other people
dumb and i can't remember the word
segment
uh we got a new one commenter of the
week
just the level of dumb [ __ ] that you
read this was the best one
so there was some video right
of this arrogant [ __ ] in a store and
he's not gonna wear a mask
and the guy's like [ __ ] 60 he's got a
ponytail
you know so he's a rebel man right and i
don't mean he's like a biker ponytail
you know like somebody with some bodies
and some sexual assault
in his background this is just some
[ __ ] guy who never cut his hair and
felt like that was his big rebellion
against capitalism and whatever right so
i'm judging him of course i'm judging
right
so he's [ __ ] just sitting there going
you're too young to understand this is
what the nazis did
this is what that's what the nazis did
this is what the nazis did
telling people wear masks so they won't
get sick trying to save lives
that's what the nazis did that's not
what the nazis did
they branded a segment of people not all
the people
a segment of the people then they
gradually worked them out of the
population and exterminated them
that's what they did they didn't say hey
everybody if you can
please try to stay six feet away plea
you have to wear a mask when you're in a
store could you please do that
i know it's hard with surround sound and
a flat screen tv
to walk out of your house and put on a
[ __ ] mask that some poor bastard who
works in a sweatshop makes 30 cents a
month
[ __ ] made it's it's so [ __ ] hard
to put that thing on right
so anyway so people you know
rational people like dude just put on a
[ __ ] mask
put on a mask by your dumb aspirin or
another band for your stupid [ __ ]
ponytail
you're so goddamn old your hairs you
know when you get so old your hair looks
like shredded wheat
just hasn't seen conditioner since i
don't know
herbert hoover right so everybody's
saying we're gonna wear a mess and then
all of these [ __ ] you know hey man
i know i really know what's going on in
the world people start commenting
and this is this was my favorite one
everyone was going like oh you're a
sheep you're this your dad
you're a globalist yeah you know
stay asleep you know like these [ __ ]
people know [ __ ] right
comment of the week somebody goes all
you have to do to know what's going on
is watch that movie
v for vendetta
that's all i have to do that's amazing
i thought i would have to have a friend
in the cia
who for some reason has a couple of
shirley temples and gets a little
loose-lipped
and then maybe then maybe then i could
find out what was going on evidently i
don't need
friends in that level of high places who
can't keep their [ __ ] mouth shut
i just have to watch a hollywood movie
called v
for vendetta these are the same [ __ ]
people
that say hollywood you know everybody
out here
a bunch of pedophiles drinking baby
blood and all of that [ __ ] but at the
same time if you make a conspiracy
theorist [ __ ] movie
that lines up with their dumb ass [ __ ]
all you have to do is watch fifa
vendetta i didn't know that and i got to
tell you this has been one of the most
frustrating confusing [ __ ]
periods of the year and uh
i don't know what streaming service has
v for vendetta but i'm going to watch it
so i understand what's going on i got it
so i don't listen to doctors
i watch a hollywood movie um
yeah some of the commenters jesus christ
i saw this thing
on uh was it gloria vanderbilt
anderson cooper's mother right and i
didn't i didn't know the whole backstory
i just knew oh he was you know i'm like
anderson cooper the [ __ ] little rich
kid but
doing the usual [ __ ] right i didn't
realize that
her son i can't remember if i talked
about this in the podcast yet her son
anderson cooper had a brother and and
the kid
unfortunately committed suicide jumped
from the 14th floor
of their apartment building in front of
their mother and immediately i was just
like oh my god
oh my god how do you how do you ever get
past that
and all of this stuff did i talk about
this i can't remember whatever i'll talk
about it again in case you missed the
last podcast
so in the comment sections
right the the [ __ ] level of meanness
they go and like you can tell she was a
devil worshiper you can tell by the
picture behind her
um talking about why anderson cooper is
gay going
you know that's what happened to you
breastfeed kids too long
uh because she was a devil worshiper
this is why her kid killed himself
and then in all of that [ __ ]
astoundingly
mean horrific [ __ ] they're writing also
these people need
jesus in their life
and i'm just sitting there like
this is this is my problem with a higher
power
or at least our theory on the higher
power that he made us in his image
and he's going to judge us and all that
and it's just like
anybody out there religious how do you
justify
that level of mean and just ignorance
like is it just always the devil
no because they actually have the devil
at what point do you look at god and be
like dude
really like you made this
you made these [ __ ] idiots and now
you're gonna [ __ ] judge them
it's your work how about taking a little
responsibility
um anyway so
um i don't know and
you know conversely on the other side
with this whole blaming the government
for everything
i'm not even going to sit here for half
a second and not entertain the fact
that that right now because that there's
allegedly this vaccine out there that's
going to work
that pharmaceutical companies are not
angling and elbowing and bribing [ __ ]
politicians and everything
for you know to be to be the ones that
put it out
to [ __ ] price gouge you know
how they're going to give it out who
they're going to give it out to like
there's not a bunch of
a bunch of [ __ ] going on of course
there is
of course there is so i just want to
reestablish my point here
my point is is i can't listen to people
who are only blaming the government in
this
and not looking at [ __ ] idiots in
atlanta
all going out to the club and [ __ ] not
wearing masks all going in because
because
they want to go out and get dressed up
and this is my new year's this is my
right as an american
that [ __ ] um what has really [ __ ]
us
on all of this i think is we haven't put
together a winning streak all right
we can't even get a three-game winning
streak because people get all [ __ ]
you know they just i don't know what it
is they watch v for vendetta and they
they
they watch that movie and they listen to
that and they don't listen to doctors so
i i don't know
whatever um and then uh there was a
great donald trump [ __ ] uh
clip of him talking to another
republican
saying i need to find these votes and
wasn't there tampering with the machines
no we haven't found that i mean inside
the
inside the machine and all of this [ __ ]
and just watching people still denying
um and i'm not even saying that joe
biden would not do something like this
he absolutely [ __ ] would
absolutely would okay he can't trust an
80 year old guy with a facelift you just
can't
you cannot cannot uh but i'm just saying
you know
it is what it is so of course
all trump people are sitting there going
like well you know it's edited you gotta
listen to the whole thing and then
people like well here's a link to the
whole thing go listen to it they're not
going to listen to it because they don't
want to hear it
so i don't know this would be like me
saying hey you know i think my seven and
nine patriots actually had a good
football season
[Music]
at some point you got to turn around and
be like look we didn't get the [ __ ]
job done
okay you want to talk fifa vendetta
let's talk about that eagles game last
night
when giant fans were sitting at home
actually
whispering fly eagles fly
because they needed them to win to get
into the goddamn playoffs
playoffs right they needed him to get in
and uh i was like up to my neck
with the kiddos at that point during the
day so i was popping in and out popping
in and out
i know the redskins came out to an early
lead i know that the eagles had some
sort of quarterback in there that wasn't
was it kirk cousins
carson wentz i always forget who the
[ __ ] there's two guys that play on the
same team i can't keep them straight
but that guy wasn't in and then they had
a backup in who was [ __ ] doing great
and at the end of the game when they
were like down by three or whatever
they take him out and put some [ __ ]
punter in to be quarterback
and they lose the [ __ ] game giants
don't make the playoffs
giants would have played the tom brady
buccaneers and then we could watch
all the people over hyping the game
acting like this is tom brady's chance
to get revenge
on a giant team while he's not a patriot
anymore and eli and tom complete and
gone
and they and watch them try and shoehorn
that [ __ ] thing and to be like
but wait is it the logo is that what it
is
so we we missed out on all of that
because they tanked and then one of my
buddies
goes that was the biggest tanking i've
ever seen in my life
and then as a patriots fan i then had to
flip out
and be like no it wasn't no it wasn't
the
biggest tanking you're ever gonna
[ __ ] see
you're ever gonna [ __ ] see is when
jim irsay in the
indianapolis colts tanked a half a
[ __ ] season
to get andrew luck they tanked
eight [ __ ] games in a row or whatever
it was six games or something like that
remember peyton manning one of the
greatest to ever do it he had that neck
problem
he [ __ ] went to europe you know some
[ __ ] was sent to his house
in his wife's name and he comes back and
he's like my neck is stronger than ever
and for the first time ever an owner was
like well we're really concerned about
your long-term health
you know finally gave a [ __ ] about a
player and they kept him on the bench
because he was like in his whatever
15th [ __ ] year whatever the hell it
was and they decided that he was washed
up and they're like and here's this
great [ __ ] kid
andrew luck coming out of stanford right
let's go get this guy and that's what
the [ __ ] they did so i mean i don't
think that that's the biggest tag having
said that
uh something went on there i don't know
i don't know why they would do that you
want to end on like a positive note
like my new england patriots beating the
2 and 13
2 and 13 team nobody wanted to play
the new york jets um
whatever um i have to say
congratulations
to the great state the great state of
ohio what a football weekend you guys
had
all right i want to say cincinnati won
too didn't they win their bowl game
uh osu
kick the [ __ ] out of clemson trounced
him
absolutely trounced him um old freckles
all freckles went 0-2 on his playoff
picks okay
which i know you guys want to give me
[ __ ] about that
college football playoffs but like
ditched
i was consistent i went 0 for two
so all you have to do is go against
whatever i predict for the championship
game you should win your bet right
no don't do that don't do that because i
want to actually give you my what i
really think is going to happen after i
told you what i thought was going to
happen this past weekend
i said take clemson in the points
and i said take alabama giving the
points
and then alabama that was it was all
going great till the final [ __ ] three
minutes of the game and that's why i try
not to bet
because i would have been losing my
[ __ ] [ __ ]
um anyway is there anything funnier than
watching
nick saban losing his [ __ ] mind
i mean the way he was yelling and the
look on his face because of the final
three minutes of that game that notre
dame scored
you would have thought he had money on
the game and then they didn't get the
onside kick i mean it was just
it's [ __ ]
you just see like special team coaches
getting yelled at
offensive coordinators defensive
coordinators it's just he just gets in
their ass
right on tv does not give a [ __ ] i would
[ __ ] love
to see dash cam footage
and then [ __ ] driving home those
coaches what they're saying all the [ __ ]
that they want to say to nick saban
you know hey you balding angry [ __ ] we
won the game by 45
you're facing the [ __ ] onside kicks
somebody's gonna get one
you [ __ ] lunatic
did you go home and kick your wife in
the [ __ ] and start calling me an [ __ ]
on tv
you know they say that you know that
they say that
um anyway
plowing ahead here um and the cleveland
browns beat the pittsburgh steelers to
make the playoffs
there was a lot of weird games yesterday
i saw that i turned on the the
chargers game like the chargers are
kicking the [ __ ] out of the chase then i
see that you know mahomes isn't playing
i don't think roethlisberger played or
whatever which could be like this genius
thing for them to easily get past the
first round of the playoffs so it's just
like all right
we'll let you play us our second team
the cleveland browns get into the
playoffs then we'll play
you next week in the playoffs and have
our status in there and kick the [ __ ]
out of you
but uh congratulations to the cleveland
browns
the first time they've made the playoffs
i don't know when when the last time
they made the playoffs unless
you're a stickler all right and you say
well the cleveland browns are also the
baltimore ravens
you know and they make the playoffs all
the [ __ ] times but at this point they
are the ravens they've changed their
names
they transitioned from cleveland to
baltimore um
all right last time a team named the
cleveland browns
browns were in the playoffs let's see
[Music]
um can i get an answer
when was the last time the bronze made
the playoffs in 2002 when they lost
the wild card round this is
what the world looked like the last time
the browns made the playoffs well jesus
christ it wasn't that long ago
it was right after 9 11 george w
w was in office um
[Music]
michael moore was complaining i for some
reason this isn't working here
all right plowing ahead whatever just
keep moving on
just go keep moving out um all right
so ohio state advances and alabama
advances which is kind of great because
these are the two most powerhouse
[ __ ] teams
in the country i will say this what did
suck about someone who didn't give a
[ __ ] either way
about the game because i know i trash
ohio state a lot but i trash their
their wine and ass fan base who every
year
we should be in the playoffs we beat
northwestern by
30. every [ __ ] year
i just get sick of them whining but i
really like
the program and i love the team colors
and all of that type of [ __ ] so i have a
weird
thing about that um but i was
as i was saying they've only played they
only played six games
and now they played seven games so they
they're really fresh
and um i don't know i think they got as
good a chance as anybody
against alabama and i'm going to be
rooting for ohio state
in this just because alabama has won so
much and i just love watching nick saban
lose his [ __ ] mind when i watch him
flipping out when something bad happens
and just turning to his immediate
the immediate coach next to him and just
yells at him it just it makes me
homesick
it's like oh i should have gone home for
the holidays
um but anyway uh the only thing i didn't
like about the [ __ ] game was
not the first targeting called the
second targeting call where it's just
like you know what the [ __ ]
it's like i know we did the kid didn't
have his head up that's what [ __ ] him
but it's like even with his head down he
was gonna hit him with his shoulder
but then the qb like he spun
he sort of spun into his head and if
anything the kid on osu got his [ __ ]
i mean i don't know clemson i was
worried his spine was gonna get
compacted
uncompressed or whatever they say and
i mean he hit him in the [ __ ] ribs
and you want you're watching running
backs every time they they go to hit the
hole they got their head down
they're able to lead with the crown of
their helmet for some [ __ ] reason and
these other
kids can't i don't know i mean
it's definitely on clemson because you
got to have your head up
but it just that just looked like the
the one where he hit the guy in the ribs
the guy's like 63 230 240. it's not like
he hit a punter
all right or a whippet this is a giant
man
running full speed trying to get a first
down in a championship [ __ ] game here
a playoff game the kid made an
incredible
[ __ ] open field tackle that just
stopped that guy in his [ __ ] tracks
and what did he he knocked the wind out
of him
and you kick him out of the [ __ ] game
i i was really
i'm not gonna lie i shut the game off at
at uh at halftime i'm like yeah this
game's [ __ ] over the two best players
are out the first kid you know like i
said i'm not bitching about that one but
i don't know that sucked and to be fair
i wish that
you know clemson players those two kids
kept their heads up instead of doing
that dumb [ __ ] and get yourself kicked
out of the game but having said that you
know
if the offensive player spins into your
[ __ ] helmet and then you hit him in
the ribs
what are you supposed to do
i mean that is i don't know that was the
only part of the game that i did not
enjoy
um oh by the way i have a part a new
podcast coming out
called any anything better and it's
going to be with paul versey for years
you guys have been saying you know what
you should do a podcast with paul versi
so i'm like all right we like to talk in
sports so we're going to talk sports i
don't know a couple times a month
um plus you know it's not like we get to
work on the road anymore with the whole
covid thing
you know and all you guys have to do if
you want to know what's going on just
watch you know just watch v for vendetta
you know we'll just watch le femme
nikita okay if you want to see what
they're going to be doing with you with
this [ __ ]
vaccine all you have to do is watch dude
where's my car
okay and it's don't watch it literally
you have to watch it for the metaphor
um so anything better which is of course
the classic paul versi dude is there
anything better than a bag of chips
with a sandwich dude
is there anything better than a new nike
pullover and a new crisp pair of jordans
is there anything better how does it get
better
um so it's going to be his positivity
with my grumpy ass
uh talking sports or whatever it's going
to be fun speaking of sports uh
celtics had some fun games this weekend
they split with the pistons
both games two-point games i saw the
first half of the first game jesus
christ we had like five points after
like six minutes
what was hilarious is we did have eight
then they realized marcus smart's uh
three-point and didn't count so then
they took it away i mean we were down by
like
15 points like eight minutes into the
game
and we somehow clawed our way back still
lost by two
but um you know that happens a lot after
you have like a big win
where everybody played great we played
memphis the day before and they were
like
you know jaylen brown had like 43 points
in three quarters
he had a career high jayson tatum had a
career high so
i always hate when that happens too and
then the next game they look like dog
[ __ ]
and you're just like why didn't i see
the letdown game coming
why didn't i bet that it always makes
sense after you go see it you know after
you're watching the game it's like
now that i know what happened how did i
not know what was going to happen before
i i watched
what was gonna happen you start beating
yourself up
um but anyway the holiday season's over
i'm hanging on to my christmas tree like
you can't believe
i had all i could do to not light it up
and i was i was big
on january 2nd you got the tree out of
the house
i was always that person um
i think that's a response responsible
person but the person
who has like the christmas tree someone
on my block did that
like it was literally the day after
christmas in the christmas tree with the
tree stand
that you could use again next year this
person could not
wait to get this [ __ ] tree out of the
house and it's just
like like wow like you really uh
weren't into the holidays were you
you know i mean what is that [ __ ] you
they should like put you on some sort of
a [ __ ] list or something
don't know i mean i'm gonna lie to you
if i didn't tell you that that i don't
have my eye on that person on the block
going like that somebody you know
during the zombie apocalypse i'm not
gonna be able to count on
like come on man let's ban the whole
block together it's like nope you're
gonna be out for yourself
um because i don't know what kind of
christmas tree we bought but this thing
just like is still drinking the water
it's still holding
you know it's not looking like a dead
tree
um even though we cut the roots off
um i don't know it still smells like
christmas in there
our lights are still up i'm a little
behind i don't give a [ __ ] it's still
the stupid pandemic still going
can i have a little bit of christmas and
extended christmas
it's my right as an american
okay and if you know if you don't
[ __ ] know what i'm talking about
about the holidays all you have to do is
watch the fast and the furious part five
to know exactly what the [ __ ] going on
out there okay
you don't need to be informed people you
don't need to have an education
you don't need to talk to experts in the
field
you just need to watch a hollywood movie
um
yeah if you want to know what's going on
with nick saban all you need to do is
watch the king of staten island
there had to promote a movie that i was
in um
all right so yesterday you know i had
this new year's resolution that i've
been doing is uh i have a salad a day
all right all the holiday sweets are
gone although i like to think that
they're not all gone because i'm still
here um
you know yesterday was like the first
day i
actually ate well since maybe before
um halloween it all started with the
pumpkin bread
and i you know i hit the crack pipe
again and i i just [ __ ]
you know it was a lot of whipped cream
in my life
nothing will make you hate yourself more
than having a late night dessert and and
then go into the fridge it's not enough
that you're having the dessert is
is when you go to get the whipped cream
i i can't
help but mutter to myself uh you fat
[ __ ] what are you doing what are you
doing you fat
pasty freckled piece of [ __ ] aren't you
unsightly enough that's right that's
right make a mountain of it
make it have actually have the whipped
cream be actually thicker than the
dessert that you're eating
you worthless [ __ ] human being but
then you take that first bite and you're
like
oh
i'm sorry people this is all i have left
all right i don't drink i'm not a weed
guy
you know my daughter's all over me with
smoking cigars
dad why are you blowing smoke so i can't
do that anymore
i have to wait till i'm on the road you
know
i actually was thinking about you know i
take these hikes around my neighborhood
maybe i could smoke a cigar then
it's like really bill you're gonna be
walking up a hill [ __ ] smoking a
[ __ ] stogie
um i don't know
i need a park bench
i just wish there was a park bench at
the end of my street i could just sit
down and people would just leave me
alone like i want to be that guy
you know sitting on a park bench feeding
pigeons while smoking a cigar
or just reading the paper
can i do that can i socially distance on
a [ __ ] park bench
um so anyway i've been getting back into
like the salad so i've been making two
simple salads i kept the recipes that
that
listener sent in which i really
appreciate and the name of that book
and um i'm gonna up my salad game here
in the uh in 2021
try to get myself uh back in shape
and i got to go on hikes and all of that
[ __ ] so what do you guys got what do
you guys got this year for new year's
resolutions
huh you got anything
i don't know what i have i just want
this whole [ __ ] thing to end i know
i've been [ __ ] on
making fun of people and all of this
stuff but like i just want us to come
together people can't we just all pull
in the same direction
every time we start to get some positive
[ __ ] let's all do this let's all do
this
it's always got to be the contrarian
going oh what about v
for vendetta what about the nazis uh
jesus
um i actually think when somebody brings
up the nazis i actually think that they
that that they actually don't know world
history because i think at this point
it's like how do you not know about the
nazis they're like the beatles of evil
people
everybody knows a beatles song right
that doesn't mean you know music
okay so like if somebody said like hey
this is like what stalin did this is
like what uh was it ivan the terrible
this is what mussolini did or maybe
maybe we get outside of
of white europe you know
hey this is what idi amin did you know
you know this kind of has a gandhi
flavor to it i don't know anybody else
um all right plowing ahead here
um so yesterday my marriage is in such a
[ __ ] great place right now
and all i did was just make a little
minor adjustment
off of that kevin bacon suggestion where
he said marriage is not a lot of work
it's a lot of fun
do i just make sure that i'm always
being silly and stupid and making my
wife laugh
and you know she saw this house that she
wanted to go look at right now like
we're going to buy
anybody no housing during a pandemic
okay um
so but i was just like you know let's
just go look because it's fun
let's go look at something big and
stupid we're not going to [ __ ] buy
right
so i'm like yeah absolutely let's go and
she's like really
you really want to do that i'm like yeah
let's do it you know she's like
wow he's actually a fun guy so then
she's in a great mood then i'm in a good
mood right happy wife happy life so all
right [ __ ] it so i put the game on pause
or whatever i record it
and um i go out to go uh to go look at
this
[ __ ] house and um
got into this house it was oddly
gigantic
it was all on one level it was shaped
like a [ __ ] horseshoe
and it was absolutely beautiful but
there wasn't
one [ __ ] thing about the house that
said that you even remotely loved your
children
first of all we walked in it looked like
the federal reserve building
and it had a giant like the door looked
like i was walking into a store
this giant door and you opened it up
and that's why i felt like i felt like i
was in one of these high-end stores like
my first instinct was like all right let
me go find a seat
while nia goes to try on some [ __ ] so we
go in there
and um they had totally redone the whole
thing
the guts of it too which was really
exciting to me so the floors were level
and i knew that all the piping
electrical everything the installation
everything was brand new
so that was very exciting but like the
kids bedrooms
were super [ __ ] small kitchen was
huge
the living room area was [ __ ] massive
like all i could picture was my daughter
on her scooter flying around it looking
these level floors how big it was
um and then you go in and it's like
the rooms were super small that indoor
outdoor
[ __ ] giant sliding windows
so you had these really small bedrooms
with these giant
sliding glass things that would go out
to the pool area because it was a
horseshoe
shape with like the pool in the middle
and um
yeah like so the kids bedrooms were
super small
but like the whole wall of one of them
looking out to the pool was all glass
so you couldn't really put any furniture
up against it because it would look
stupid it's also supposed to open
i'm like this is weird and then you go
into the master bedroom
and it's like it's almost like a whole
other house
the giant walk-in closet huge [ __ ]
bathroom
and all of this [ __ ] and then behind
that was like you walked out and there
was this second little [ __ ] area
where you could like
um it was like a man cave indoor outdoor
like flat screen tv a full bar with a
fridge
and then behind that was like this other
little
building thing that had like a gym in it
it was [ __ ] ridiculous it was huge
[ __ ] huge but it was just like yeah
[ __ ] your kids this is all about you
for if you want to entertain and have
your friends come over and do some blow
after you put the kids to bed right
so i'm sitting you know we went once
through the house i'm like wow yeah that
was really
amazing this is beautiful i like looking
at a big stupid house i look at it
i ain't [ __ ] buying it okay i'm not
[ __ ] buying it right
so i'm sitting there and i'm like all
right well cool thanks for showing us
the house
and then my wife's like hey i just want
to walk around again blah blah
and next thing you know i'm sitting
there for like a [ __ ] half an hour
and she's
pushing her kid around the stroller and
i'm like wait a minute
what's good is she falling in love with
this house what the [ __ ] is going on
here
so as i'm sitting there uh the real
estate agents are really cool one of
them comes over
with an ipad and starts to explain to me
that this is a smart house
and i sat there for like seven straight
minutes going uh-huh
yeah okay uh-huh as this person had to
explain to me
how to open the curtains which app to
[ __ ] hit
on this laptop now at this point i'm
feeling claustrophobic
it's like i just want to get out of here
this this feels like i walked into a
scientology building and now i can't get
out
and uh eventually we ended up
you know walking out or whatever and uh
uh
the real estate agent said to me
uh so what'd you think you know and i
was like yeah i didn't like
i didn't like it just didn't feel
kid-friendly and all of that [ __ ] and
then i found out later that my my wife
actually
loved it because my wife is like you
know she's like
she's got me watching [ __ ] like uh
she doesn't have me watching this [ __ ]
actually my drum teacher got me into
this [ __ ] i was watching this
documentary last night
on michelle basquiat
who i've never understood
his artwork i was just going like i must
be stupid because this looks like
my [ __ ] high school notebook and
i started to watch this documentary and
the more i watched it and the more i
learned
about the guy all of a sudden i started
looking at his paintings and i started
to get it for the first time
a little bit i mean i don't get that
somebody paid 110 million dollars for a
[ __ ] painting
okay i mean i don't want to
overstate this here but that sounds like
some v for vendetta [ __ ]
okay like just watch fifa vendetta if
you want to know how somebody has
110 million dollars laying around to
invest in a [ __ ] painting
okay all you need to watch is freddie
got fingered
that's all i'm saying um
yeah so she's like into that type of
stuff so we ended up leaving and we had
this
really mature conversation about it
the whole [ __ ] thing and i was just
saying like listen we spent all this
money on a house
okay to the point if i went to sell it
now we're gonna lose [ __ ] money
all right we got a great house it's a
cozy house
i like that when we're in the tv room
we're all on top of each other we don't
need like walkie-talkies to [ __ ] talk
to each other
and then also there's a certain price
point that you go past in a [ __ ]
house
and it's like what what the [ __ ] are we
doing here
okay you want to play nine million
dollars a year in property taxes
this is like [ __ ]
you know i i never forget what my
brother told me he told me a long time
ago he goes you know what wealth is
this is when we're really young he goes
walking into a mall being able to buy
anything and then you don't
and i just told her i just said listen
like that i don't
that house would be great for you and me
it wouldn't be great for the kids and i
started talking about that and she goes
yeah you know what you're right and i
feel like
the rooms we have in our houses like
they can stay in those rooms and blah
blah get the [ __ ] plumbing fixed
oh boy that's the biggie that's the
biggie this year
i have one last bathroom that i have to
do
and it's gonna cost me a small [ __ ]
fortune
and he's gonna have to open up walls in
the ceiling and all of that [ __ ] [ __ ]
but once we get that done i think
we should be all good
and uh i don't know i'm just really
psyched that my wife is [ __ ] cool
because i knew that she fell in love
with that house it was really like it
was
beautiful it was beautiful but it was
just like
you know all right well okay we can get
this and i'll be on the road for the
rest of my life um
which by the way there's no road gigs
anymore i'll be standing by
the side of the [ __ ] highway i guess
doing 16 shows in eight days
uh which once again thank you to
everybody who came out in texas man
i've still been thinking about how much
fun i had
and how much people give a [ __ ] about
stand-up comedy that they would come out
you know and sit in a field that could
hold you know
4 000 people and only have you know 80
people there
you know it was the sound of the cars
were driving by and [ __ ] um
that was a lot of fun um oh and lastly
but not leastly uh
i've really gotten in to filming myself
playing drums i'm over the
whole oh god i hate the way i look and i
just been watching it oh my god
um i'm a [ __ ] mess
i thought i was killing it everybody i
thought i
was [ __ ] killing it i [ __ ] s
oh my god i stink holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] i stink
i was doing this fill right single
stroke really fast fill and i had my
pinkies out
i didn't think i had my pinkies out i
used to watch videos go look at that guy
he's got his pinkies out
all your fingers are supposed to be on
the stick thinking i was doing that
oh camera don't lie man the video camera
does not
[ __ ] lie jesus christ
what a [ __ ] show but i've already gotten
better by filming myself so that's what
i do
um and um
i don't know like i said my foot is the
fastest it's ever been
still not up to speed but uh i'm hanging
in there so that's what i do i eat
salads every day
and i'm filming myself playing drums and
i'm just gonna keep working on
the same [ __ ] licks that i've been
working on
and then also trying to come up with
some something that actually maybe that
i came
you know made instead of just trying to
ape what somebody else did all right
anyway
let's get into the uh let's get into the
reads here for the week here
indochino um oh by the way yeah send me
you know i don't care what your politics
are you wouldn't know that at the top of
this podcast okay i probably came off
like a [ __ ]
liberal larry but i'm not i really am i
i
want everybody to come together okay but
you know
when it does come to a moment we got to
call a spade a spade
all right like you're listening to that
[ __ ] trump conversation he's trying
some underhanded [ __ ] now if i listen to
a joe biden [ __ ] thing doing the same
thing
i'm gonna call out joe biden okay that's
all i'm [ __ ] doing here
so don't get all into your team colors
um all right everybody it's indochito
all right make every moment an
opportunity to look your best
with indochino perfectly fitted custom
clothes
are more affordable than you might think
talk about an outfit or a favorite piece
of clothing that you feel especially
confident in
or that you get a lot of compliments on
well you know something
i always feel like when i wear a
tracksuit that
everybody you know as long as it has the
sweatpants where
the pockets are deep enough that i can
put my phone in there unlike the pair
that i have on right now which
they just some corporate [ __ ] figured
out like hey you know what
if we have material inside where the
pockets are supposed to be that are
just big enough that you can keep one
peanut m
m in there technically there's still
pockets and think about this is a pair
of adidas [ __ ] sweatpants
well i don't know about nike or any of
that [ __ ] i'm gonna d this guy i can
tell you this right now if you get a
pair of adidas sweatpants
make sure you put your pants hands in
the [ __ ] pockets
because this goddamn thing if i even i'm
gonna be talking like i start i think
about sitting down and my phone falls
out of my [ __ ] pockets
all right but that doesn't happen within
no chino hey we're back on the road here
uh there's never a bad time to look good
especially with indochino
offers made to measure custom clothing
at a more affordable price
indochino offers completely custom
fitted suits
coats and casual wear at surprisingly
affordable prices
customize everything from the fabric and
the lining to the lapel
shape and monogram the choice is yours
and since your order is made to your
exact measurements
each piece will fit you and your style
perfectly unless you start eating like
an animal
or starve yourself after you order it
all right so try to remain consistent
all right the best part indochino suits
start at just 299
with all customizations included book a
virtual appointment and shop online at
indochino.com
i n d o c h i
n o dot com and right now
you'll get 30 off any purchase of 399.
or more when you enter the code burr at
checkout that's 30
off any purchase of 3.99
three gretzky or more at indochino.com
promo code burr
okay here we go dude me undies me undies
oh bill bird's a [ __ ] [ __ ] doo doo
doo me undies me undies i don't care
about your politics
none of this is gonna [ __ ] rhyme
put on me undies on your face have you
junk out but don't breathe on me so we
can get back to normal life
and go to the movies all right meundies
it's almost the new year
you know it is the new year which means
we all get to hit the beautiful refresh
button
uh there's not an actual button though
unless we're talking about refreshing
your unders
undies drua then yes there's a button
for that
after the year we just had me undies
wants you to take some much deserved
time
for yourself in the softest undies in
loungewear
get them delivered right to your door by
the with the
no by the click of a button i thought it
was with a click of the button
uh when was the last time you refreshed
your undress drawer you [ __ ] animal
could you step up your comfy game in
different prints color styles oh this is
a must read
all right i have to read this see
i'll tell you right now all you got to
do is watch fifa vendetta to know why
they want me to read this here
um now that's now that it's dark out by
like 4 p.m all you want to do is become
one with the couch
me undies gets it that's why you want to
uh you want to help
we want to help oh they want to help you
step up your cozy game
[ __ ] i'm getting destroyed on this here
their loungewear and undies are super
soft
and come in everything from classic to
adventurous prints
huh you want to have a [ __ ]
wildebeest right over your dick they got
it
i don't know if they do but they
probably should uh they've literally
made for your couch and guess what
you don't ever have to leave the couch
again with my undies with the miandi's
membership
a subscription that sends new pairs
right to your door
what are they suggesting here jesus
christ oh i get it stay on the couch
become a fat [ __ ]
and then you got to order more underwear
oh uv for vendetta [ __ ] me undies
uh with site-wide savings and exclusive
sales you'll automatically pay less for
everything meundies has a great offer
for my listeners for anytime first-time
purchasers
uh you get 15 off and free shipping me
undies also has their problem free
i'm a problem free free philosophy
if you're not satisfied with any product
for any reason they'll refund or
exchange it
no caveats no questions to get fifteen
percent off your first order and
free shipping go to myandi's.com that's
look who it is look who it is it's
simply safe
isn't this something we all want to feel
simply safe everyone wants to keep their
home and family safe whether it's from a
break-in a fire flooding or medical
emergency
simply safe home security delivers
award-winning 24 7 protection
with simply safe you don't just get an
arsenal of cameras and sensors
you get the best professional monitors
in the business they got you back
day and night ready to send police fire
or emts
when you need them most straight to your
door simply safe has an
arsenal of sensors and cameras that
protect every inch of your home you can
set it up yourself in about 30 minutes
it's super easy
that simply say then simply says
professional takeover monitoring your
home
what then simply says professionals take
over monitoring your home
24 7 and ready to send help the moment
there's an alarm
plus with simply safe there's no
long-term contract no hidden fees or
installation costs
right now my listeners get a free home
security camera when you purchase a
simply safe system at simplysafe.comburr
uh you get a 60-day risk-free trial so
there's nothing to lose visit
simplysafe.com
that's s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e
dot-com b-u-r-r for your free security
camera today that's simplysafe.com
all right we got zip recruit oh zip
fifa vendetta recruiter
um it's finally a new year a time
a time to reassess your business goals
for 2021 and determine for resources
what
to determine the resources you'll need
to achieve them
[ __ ] that's where zip
dot com slash burke comes in talk about
how challenging hiring is
example finding time to hire while
focusing on the rest of your business
screening through too many applicants
competition with other companies to
attract talent etc
and how zip recruiter makes it easy work
in the url
once at the beginning oh i see what i'm
supposed to do here
you know people with ziprecruiter.com
um i really found it a lot easier to
hire
a sidekick on this show i just send the
thing out and all these applicants come
in and i don't have to try to go down to
the comedy clubs where nobody's at to
try and see where the funny people are
at
you know when you post on a job on
ziprecruiter it gets sent
out to over 100 top job sites with just
one click
then zip matches technology scans
thousands matching technology scans
thousands of resumes and profiles to
send you
the most qualified people to your job if
you're really interested in
a candidate you can even invite them to
apply for your job
with one click zip
sends them an email from you
and you stand out from the competition
okay it's so effective that four out of
five employ four to five employers who
post on zipper crew to get a quality
candidate
through the site within the first day i
mean time is money people
this is what they're saying you'll get a
[ __ ] guy the first goddamn day it
looks like
and right now you can try ziprecruiter
for free at ziprecruiter.com
that's ziprecruited.com burr spell out
burr b-u-r-r
just go to zip
dot com slash burp all right this is the
last one everybody
hymns uh you know you've heard us
talking about hymns
and how they are helping guys look their
best if you haven't
it's time to see what they're all about
problem the best way to prevent more
hair loss is to do something about it
while you still have some
[ __ ] uh why do guys turn to weird
solutions or do nothing
when they can turn to medicine and for
hims.com
a one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
sexual wellness
for men it's time to write a new chapter
uh one in which you have heya thanks to
science baldness can be
optional hymns is helping you guys be
the best version of themselves with
licensed medical providers and fda
approved products to help treat hair
loss
no snake oil pills or gas station
counter supplements prescription
solutions backed by science
for hymns connects to your you to
licensed medical professionals online
you can save hours completely
confidential and discreet
answer a few quick questions a medical
professional will review
and if they determine it's right for you
you can prescribe your prescription to
treat hair loss
that is ship wait they can prescribe you
medication to treat your hair loss that
is shipped directly to your door
today hymns is giving you their best
offer yet
and if you're not happy with your
results after 90 days hymns
will give you a full refund refund and
right now
my listeners can get their first visit
absolutely free
with for hims.com bird that's for
hims.com
bird b-u-r-r-e-d disclaimer
must include prescription products
require an online consultation with help
with a health care provider who will
determine if a prescription is
appropriate
restrictions apply see website for full
details and important safety
information remember that's for hims.com
bird
all right there we go by the way have
you guys been seeing on uh youtube and
instagram this this
this freaking workout guy right shredded
dude
trying to say you know you can get on a
treadmill and run three miles a day
seven days a week
you're not gonna lose weight it doesn't
work it's never worked it's like
the [ __ ] it doesn't if you get on a
treadmill
and run three miles a day seven days a
week you're absolutely gonna lose weight
unless
you get off the treadmill and eat a
sleeve of [ __ ] cookies
and whatever this person is selling me
is not gonna work
unless i'm eating right it's all about
diet people
okay you don't even have to [ __ ] work
out you if you eat the way you're
supposed to eat
and then you go for a [ __ ] walk
around the block you're gonna have
you're gonna lose weight you just
are don't listen to these [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right these [ __ ] idiots well you
gotta have a
i gotta have a mirror now that talks to
mirror mirror on the wall
i need a personal trainer in my house
you don't
you know you need to read up on
nutrition you need to eat right
um i always get sucked into those things
uh there's there's a food out there that
helps boost
male testosterone and in the next half
hour
i'm gonna reveal to you and you're
sitting just [ __ ] tell me what the
food is
for so long people have been telling you
to eat these other foods when you
actually should be eating this food over
here
and when we tell you what this food is
it is going to change your life
and you can have a body like this it's
just for [ __ ] tell me
28 minutes later i don't i usually hang
in there for like [ __ ] eight minutes
and then i just i just
all right you got me all right so
oh wait i gotta tell you about an
amazing [ __ ] movie that i have never
seen once upon a time in the west
starring jason robards charles bronson
henry fonda it is [ __ ] amazing
and if you write scripts you should
definitely [ __ ] watch it
because all that sid field book you know
you can the first 10 pages you do this
by page 22 all of that is out the
[ __ ] window
know this the first scene is 11 minutes
long
and i think there's like five lines of
dialogue
that's it it's just people giving each
other looks sitting around
it is it's two hours and 40 minutes it
is a [ __ ]
masterpiece [ __ ] masterpiece sergio
leon
and if you watch it you you see that
movie like tarantino
has watched this movie a zillion times
because i always wondered when i watched
once upon a time in hollywood
when he did that great shot of that kid
texts
from the manson family riding the horse
and how breathtaking and big and uh and
just cinematic that moment was
when you watch this movie like oh this
is what this kid this is what a kid
can't say he's a kid this is what
tarantino grew up on
movies like this it's just henry fonda
is playing the bad guy
i would sit i would sit down and watch
it again it was the fastest two hours
and 40 minutes of my life i absolutely
[ __ ] loved it
and i guess it's part of a trilogy of or
at least two there's one other movie
once upon a time and something else
i have to watch all of them um
absolutely incredible all right anyway
seoul
dear billy preston nice nice [ __ ]
will it go around
in circles
with uh like a bird up in the sky
he also played keys in uh the beetles
uh check out the movie soul on disney
plus you know what i [ __ ]
i started to watch that i me and my wife
that's on our list
to watch i um i love the animation and
also anything with jamie foxx i'm gonna
watch
um it's not french but i think you like
it jamie foxx
and quest love do the voices i didn't
know quest was in that
the message is solid and solid and i
think you'd appreciate it
okay i'm in i'm beyond in all right
all right you made the books dear billy
dried up booze bag
i got my kid a little golden book story
i didn't know this
this is really cool little golden books
i have a bunch of those for my daughter
and she loves them i grew up on these
things uh the mandalorian
the little golden book the mandalorians
so i'm reading to him on christmas night
i turn the page and boom
there's old baldi congratulations on
another first in your career thanks for
the laughs ah that's so [ __ ] cool
that's really cool all right 60s
beauties
uh dear billy old school i've been
watching a lot of old movies
i'm really digging these old school
chicks faye dunaway and thomas
thomas crown affair you know i've never
seen that i got to see that
is like walking magic audrey hepburn
in charade bridgette bardot oh let me
tell you bridget bardo
um it's funny i'm infatuated by them and
they didn't even need to twerk
do you think we'll ever return to that
happy medium of appeal
somewhere between the pilgrims and the
slobs on
instagram ah a thousand thanks for this
[ __ ] email exactly
this whole [ __ ] [ __ ] of like i'm
taking control of my sexuality no you're
you're
you're acting like a [ __ ] that's what
you're doing
all right this whole [ __ ] thing where
you got to dress like a superhero when
you work out and have [ __ ] shorts up
your [ __ ] ass
when you're working out is that you
don't need all of that
you're not around like you know heavy
machinery and you could get dragged into
one and get killed or like on like
farming equipment
um
i still i still pretty much dress the
same goddamn way
no that's not true because back in the
day you had like the real sweatpants not
like the tracksuit things
um i actually got a pair of those
somebody gave them to me when i was out
on the road
they gave me a little bag of uh they had
some company or something like that so
you know i took some of the stuff gave
the rest to dean delray
uh but i have these old school
sweatpants i [ __ ] love them
i like them more than these track suit
[ __ ] things they're soft they're
comfortable
you know and they're great from when you
put whipped cream on top of a dessert
[Music]
you can't feel yourself getting this fat
um
yeah do i think we'll ever go back to
that um
yeah i think but i think it'll be more
like a
hipster movement type of thing
where people sort of embrace that
because
what's gonna happen is
there's there's gonna be like
you would think but i don't know maybe
you maybe they won't you would think
that you they'll reach a point where
the only next step would be for a woman
to be like completely nude pulling her
[ __ ] lips apart
is is is about is i don't know what you
know to try and top one another
i i think um
those classic looks like audrey hepburn
i mean
there's nothing anybody's doing today
that i've seen that is
is just better than that and then i also
feel like like the old school movie
stars the guys back then
you know they would just have like a
black suit with a white shirt and a
black tie
and they weren't like overly worked out
and developed they were just in shape
i don't know they look more like men uh
that's why once upon a time in the west
it's just
it's some man [ __ ] that's [ __ ] all it
is and i don't want to ruin the movie
but i want to talk about it so bad it's
just [ __ ]
you know i don't know if
if you saw v for vendetta you're going
to love this movie um
no i don't i don't think so because
there's so many people on
instagram that their talent is
their amazing body and they have to
[ __ ] show it off
um because what else they can do they
can't write they can't rap
they can't tell jokes it's it is what it
is but they're not pretty enough to be
signed by a modeling agency so they got
to walk around with half their hoo-ha
hanging out i mean it is what it is
and uh you can't blame the [ __ ]
because people
[ __ ] want to look at the [ __ ] so
there you go do i think it's gonna come
back uh
no you can bring it back though
you can dress classy try to bring some
class to the room
you can find a woman out there sure
there's a woman watching movies like
that wants to incorporate that style
with a little bit of [ __ ] from today
that would be cool
i have no idea last thing you want to do
is ask ask me about fashion
um all right
wife claims to be great but it's
actually the worst oh boy here we go
here we go we're going in going getting
in quick here
um bildo
that's probably not the first time
you've been called that no it is not
but since you like to be called
defensive things i do i'll start there
well thank you uh i'm writing since you
seem to be
rather forward in your advice instead of
taking a nice guy approach
i'd like to know what i should ah wait a
minute
wait a minute here we go
oh it's not playing why i want to play i
got to get a [ __ ] someone in here
it's time
all right asking me for advice always a
dangerous thing
always a dangerous thing i'm not a
licensed professional
i'm a [ __ ] jerk off but here's my two
cents
um i did watch i did watch v for
vendetta at one point i did see that
movie i have seen that movie
i'm writing you since you seem to be
rather forward but i've been with a
woman for 10 years
we're married with one seven-year-old
boy
who is the absolute apple of my eye
early in our marriage it became very
obvious that she didn't contribute
much to the household we lived in a
one-bedroom apartment and i did most of
the cleaning
because she never bothered to do any of
it do you realize how many guys are in
this situation
it's this weird thing where feminism
told them that oh you're on you're
making the guy a sandwich
and you're cleaning up and what are you
his [ __ ] slave
you know which i say is all well and
good
as long as you then go out and get a
[ __ ] job
and you're bringing money into the house
then i don't have your problem
cleaning up as much but if you're making
half the [ __ ] messes you should be
cleaning up half the [ __ ] messes
um i paid all i paid all of the bills
because if it was left to her to do it
we would have
have late fees every month on all bills
we both worked so she was tired at the
end of the day and never cared to cook
this is understandable but at the same
but
at the same time it's frustrating
because she always brags about
her amazing cooking skills i know and
you worked all day so you're tired too
uh within a few months after the wedding
she almost stopped having sex with me
oh wow dude at this point
10 years later it's limited to about
once or twice a year
she's also basically let herself go she
was about 135 pounds
when we were married but she's probably
over 200 now
for some that might not be a ton but
she's only
five too after about a year of this
marriage disaster i wanted to let her go
but her dad came over to attempt to work
out our differences
i decided to give it another ch and then
he got pregnant right i decided to give
it another chance
within a few weeks after this
conversation she got pregnant
and i was obviously not happy about it
yeah i wonder how that happened
um she probably pulled the goalie on you
there she promised once she became a
stay-at-home mom
that behavior would be different she's
she'd start to clean more cook more go
to the gym but of course none of that
ever happened
having discussion about her lack of
effort never goes well
she'll sleep till nine and just watch
youtube most of the day
wow dude this laziness even occurs after
6 pm and puts me in the spot where i
must
take care of our boy or nobody else will
i walk him to school every morning and
put him to bed
and read to him almost every night the
effort she puts in to raise our boy is
atrocious
dude this is depressing on top of all
this
she has lied to me about her clothing
purchases for years
she's also started a business using my
social security number without any
discussion
she has proceeded to charge cards to
abound over a hundred thousand dollars
to spice my attempts to stop it
well dude you're not you're not trying
hard enough what is she holding you down
punching you in the face taking the
cards take the [ __ ] cards away from
her
she has said that she wants a divorce
but i have asked for us to work it out
every argument she pushes it again i'm
starting to think it's the right move
but i'm terrified for my little boy and
his needs
i know she won't take care of him as
needed courts usually side with the
woman
i'm also scared the courts will make me
pay her business credit card balances on
top of child support
see ladies listen to this [ __ ] guy's
story
she's truly the worst wife that ever
existed but
says i'm only i only point out her worst
traits
honestly is there a good trait i
struggle to find any
her cooking too little evidence to
conclude
hoping for a decent response from a
responsible [ __ ] like you
wow dude
if she was like half a decent mother i
would just say
i mean everything points out you just
got to walk away from this person
you got to walk away if the kid wasn't
involved you walk away
and who gives a [ __ ] if they put the 100
grand on you okay if you stayed with it
would become 200 grand
all right um so now all i got to do is
if you're going to stay or if you're
going to leave
all right if you're going to stay you
got to take her credit cards away from
her
that's it all right you have to start
having
ultimatums all right
and she has to get her [ __ ] [ __ ]
together this is it dude
you need ultimatums here i'm taking away
the credit cards
and you have to get your [ __ ] together
or this isn't gonna work out
and that's [ __ ] it that's it
because you are literally a prisoner
in this [ __ ] relationship granted
this is just your side of it but it's
pretty vivid
so um i might talk to a lawyer
before you have this conversation and
just see if there's a way to prove
that she's as bad as you're saying that
you would get custody
um because reality
of what you have going on here dude this
is a divorce where you want you want
to go for full custody
um and if that's what you're leaning
towards i would go to a lawyer first
without her knowing and find out
what evidence you need to prove that you
should at least get 50
of being with your kid because here's
the thing too you don't want your kid
not your kid still loves
her mom unconditionally so
um you sound like a great dad you sound
like you're you know you
out there you're earning money you're
not doing anything wrong you're putting
up with
a ridiculous level of childish [ __ ]
behavior
um it sounds like you've sat down and
tried to talk to her it hasn't [ __ ]
worked
um
you know what dude i would get out of
this i get out of this because she's
just
because what's going to happen is she's
going to end up having 300 grand
in [ __ ] credit card debt and then
she's going to put that on you
and then try to get custody and all of
this [ __ ] um
i don't know or maybe try to give her
one more chance but i would talk to a
lawyer first
find out what your [ __ ] options are
so you can play this as perfectly as you
can
um i'm hoping in the
in the future court systems will realize
that the the guy
is not always the person that's wrong in
a relationship
and it isn't always best for the kid to
be with
the mother um i understand why that is
you know watching my daughter how she
reacted to to having a baby brother and
just their instincts is [ __ ]
incredible
but like that doesn't mean that there's
not selfish sociopaths or [ __ ] pieces
of [ __ ]
that happen to have vaginas out there um
all right
so that's what i would do sir i would go
talk to her laurie and find out what my
[ __ ] options are
and um
you know the other option is you just
hang in there to your son's 18 and then
you just [ __ ] pull the rip cord and
get the [ __ ] out
but by then dude by then how much money
in credit card debt has she racked up
you know then there's a diabolic side
where you just you encourage her to keep
eating and you hope she drops of a
[ __ ] heart attack
there's a lot of options here none of
them friendly all right
girlfriend finds another man attractive
finds other men attractive
all right sup bill i'm 23 year old from
new hampshire and i've recently met a
new woman
we've been dating for a few months now
and she is damn near perfect
one of the only things she does that
bothers me is she will often talk about
how
attractive she finds certain male
celebrities oh give me a break those
aren't real people
she will even post things about these
certain celebrities on her instagram
story from time to time
basically boasting about how hot she
thinks they are my question is do i have
the right to tell her to stop
i have no problem with her finding other
people attractive everyone
everyone does but when she boats
publicly about them
it makes me feel like [ __ ] and a bit
insecure
um i mean come on man i mean the [ __ ]
i mean brad pitt is brad pitt ryan
gosling's ryan gosling i mean
they're going to find him attractive
they're never going to run into him
you know and if she wants to do that she
gives a [ __ ] i i personally i
wouldn't bother me he goes am i being a
[ __ ] or my feelings here valid
your feelings are always valid what you
have to wonder
is where they're coming from
um anyways he goes i've told her it
bothers me before but i'm not trying to
be controlling of her
so she still does it from time to time i
would not do this
and i find it disrespectful well it
seems like she
she lowered it and just from time to
time she does it
anyway sure there are other people out
there and she can find some
find some attractive but when she
flaunts her feelings about them to the
world
it makes me wonder why i am pouring my
heart out to this girl if she's going to
give attention to other men
even if they are unattainable thanks
and stay safe kid uh well this is what i
would do
why don't you post if you want to be a
vindictive v for vendetta
vindictive lunatic you should post and
say how hot you find uh
sally sugar tits whatever the [ __ ] is
the hot chick i'm too old to know
anymore
yeah why don't you uh oh margot robbie
once upon a time in hollywood why don't
you [ __ ] post some pictures of her
with her
dirty feet up on that movie seat um
yeah but that's a dangerous game to play
that's a dangerous game to play um i
think
that you know it's just
she's just into this [ __ ] the way you
might be into sports that's all
where you would post a picture of some
[ __ ] linebacker going this guy's an
absolute beast
they're like oh my god this guy's a
[ __ ] dreamboat i mean
i i really wouldn't you know if she
suggested that you move to hollywood
even if you were in hollywood she's
still never gonna meet these [ __ ]
people so i mean i i
of all the things you could be upset
about i would let that i would let that
one go
um i would let it go personally i would
um all right top but having said that if
it was the other way around and you were
posting about um
one of these stars out here women you
know i think that she would and she had
a [ __ ] problem about it
you without a doubt would have to
[ __ ] stop
i mean and that that is the male female
dynamic in a nutshell is basically they
can kind of do whatever the [ __ ] they
want
because the narrative out there is if
you say that they should stop doing
something because it hurts your feelings
that you're being controlled let me even
say i'm not trying to be controlling
am i just a [ __ ] right because you
actually she's doing something that
bothers you
the other way around is you need to
validate your feelings
it's you know it's the you know the
reason why women always talk about that
horse stud
double standard is because if they
looked at all the other double standards
those are all wins for them
um all right top five dumb questions
gay guy hey all right
finally here we go yeah somebody
different right now okay
dear billy pale oh what i do for a pale
ale right now oh
let me tell you i've actually had dreams
lately that i had a drink
um i hope that you and your lovely wife
and your little ones are healthy and
happy thank you your podcast
never cease to make me laugh and
distract me from the [ __ ] in my
world so thank you very much for that
also the great andrew themillis always
crushes it with the music
so big shout out to him as well look at
this all right
i'm a 29 year old gay guy living in
canada
uh that detail will become important
shortly
um why is it too cold up there to wear
more revealing outfits
[Music]
sorry it was a layup uh this list is a
spin-off
of your dumb questions for people who
work
with the public segment these are my top
five dumb questions people have asked me
when they find out that i'm gay all
right this should be great in my
experience these questions are almost
always asked of gay guys at some point
in their life
okay oh you're gay do you know my friend
insert gay guy's name a no
despite what you may have heard we don't
all know each other
unless we're both from the same small
town in which case
i probably do know your gay friend and i
might also know some of your
friends whom you think are straight oh
that's great
uh so which one of you two is the girl
in the relationship
people say that i get annoyed by this
one i know exactly
what they're asking it's just a rude way
of saying it
being the sarcastic smart ass i am i
respond with
uh we're both guys and we're gay having
a girl in the relationship would defeat
the point
but to plow ahead and answer their real
question who [ __ ] who
it depends some guys prefer to be the
top the one [ __ ] others
prefer to be the bottom the one being
[ __ ]
and others like to switch it up
we call them versatile verse for short
pronounce
verse as in this as in a song
uh some guys prefer to do mostly top or
mostly bottom but are still
sexually flexible we call those guys
verse tops
and verse bottoms respectively it's also
it's all about preference and what feels
good also you should entitle yourself
you should entitle your next special
sexually flexible
uh why are you gay
uh for the reasons you're not i was born
this way
i'm not homophobic but i just don't like
when gay guys stare or check me out
not a question i know but why does it
bother you if someone finds you
attractive
well in defense of that guy it all
depends how they're looking at you
you know what i mean if someone's
leering yeah somebody's just taking a
glance over at you you got to take the
compliment like all right look at me
i got a peel on both sides of the fences
right
uh side of the fence not the fences both
sides of the fence right
but if someone's like staring at you to
the level it's like do i gotta like
fight this dude
you know is this guy gonna come [ __ ]
at me here um
he goes i don't get uncomfortable when a
lady checks me out well she also can't
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you in the ass either right i mean
there was there was like a different
thing here
right a little bit i'm just saying
i'm saying like if a gay guy is looking
at me checking me out that does not make
me uncomfortable
if he's a [ __ ] creep and he's bigger
than me yes that makes me uncomfortable
i don't think there's anything wrong
with that
um yeah if i look over at some guy and
be like if he wanted to there's nothing
i could do about it yeah that's gonna
make me uncomfortable
uh take it as a compliment if you're
straight then i know you're not
interested
so i wouldn't try anything yeah that's
because you're a [ __ ] good person
as an aside let me just say that remarks
preface with dude i'm not homophobic but
are always followed by homophobia in the
same way that statements with dude i'm
not a racist but always
preface racism yeah that's pretty
accurate uh
when do you when did you know you were
gay
he said answer when did you know you
were straight about the same time you
realized your dick was getting hard for
chicks
mine was getting hard for the fellas uh
the difference is i had to pretend i was
straight because it felt like what
that's what the world around me expected
and that's what's [ __ ] wrong
that's so it's so [ __ ] stupid that in
20 20 21 now
you just can't like what you like um
bonus
oh my god you're gay
will you be my gay best friend i [ __ ]
hate people like that
who collect gay people as like pets
and they call them my gays the worst
answer honestly i usually laugh at this
one it's pretty harmless generalization
it indicates that the person is totally
okay with me being gay
well aren't they also using your your
gayness
to like enhance like look at me and how
open i am and they use you as like an
accessory
anyways as long as they don't go around
introducing me as their gay friend like
i'm some token in their entourage well
there's your answer
it's all good there's a whole lot more
to me than just being gay
i hope this list made you chuckle at
least a little bit i wish you a happy
new year with
a lot more laughter and a lot less
covert have a great day and go [ __ ]
yourself p.s
please come up to canada and do a show
uh when you're
able to tour again my friends and i are
dying to see you on stage
hey there's nothing i'd like to do more
you know i just can't tour canada this
time of year because
they're going to be outdoor shows um
although i should do it if you [ __ ]
guys can stand outside maple leaf
guns i think you can stand out there and
watch a comedian
all right armored guard uh oh i'm gonna
throw that out there can i do a show
outside of uh maple leaf gardens
where you guys stood there and watch uh
the play on playoffs
uh armored guard dear mr burr i'm a
supervisor
for an armored truck company and i'm
mostly involved with atm work
here are the five dumbest questions
statements i encounter from the public
all right i would ask have you ever
taken any money um i hear these
jokes all the time got any free samples
or oh just put that in my honda over
there
hardy har [ __ ] har oh every time you
walk in with the money bag don't get me
wrong i'm glad people are being positive
around me instead of coming at me with a
rusty
what the [ __ ] is that word oh rusty
chlamydia covered knife
very specific but the most but the job
is very stressful
stressful and those stupid joke over
and those same stupid jokes over and
over and over again drive me nuts
and drive me into wanting white people
on the news
did you forget some words here and those
stupid joke over and over again drive me
into wanting to go white people on the
news level crazy okay sorry i read it
wrong
okay working around all that money do
you ever get tented
do you think all that money is counted
i'm not risking years in jail getting my
s
slight love handles squeezed stealing
less money
than it would ever be worth to go on the
run with um
here's another one so what would you do
if i tried taking that
from you right now i personally don't
give a [ __ ] about the insured money
but don't [ __ ] ask a guy with the
vest and a gun a dumb question
to make him paranoid i literally read
news stories every couple weeks about
someone in the industry getting shot in
the face
also this job is stressful as hell don't
try to rob
us because i might want to take the
stress out tossing you around like a rag
doll
hey can you stop for a minute so i can
use that atm
the damn thing is open i've pulled this
[ __ ] out and
b book bebop beeped some [ __ ]
numbers already
how do you not have enough common sense
to realize it's down and i need to
finish before it's usable
jesus christ my personal favorite
are you serious right now i'm busy and
can't wait
you could have done this [ __ ] at a
better time hey you dumb ignorant
[ __ ] hat that's a new one this isn't the
only thing i have today i have a whole
route and i work on average 10 to 12
hours a day
you can either wait like 10 minutes or
learn some time management skills
to not run this behind someone once was
actually getting so mad
they couldn't use the atm they actually
yelled get a [ __ ]
job at me i got worried for a second and
called my boss to verify
i indeed was doing this in a uniform as
a job
because i sure as [ __ ] wouldn't do this
for free
jesus christ who the [ __ ] why would you
say that to some [ __ ] guy
bulletproof vest and a gun what would
you do if i [ __ ]
just took the if i tried to grab that
back i blow your [ __ ] brains out
you dumb [ __ ] all right so that's the
podcast this one was really all over the
place
uh thank you everybody who's been
writing in over the years happy new year
to everybody
i hope this vaccine works i hope you
take it if it works
um i hope i think we should all watch v
for vendetta though we're gonna try to
figure some [ __ ] out that's
it go [ __ ] yourselves i will talk to you
i'll check in on you on thursday there